let's get to it let's go from new
england and tampa bay
to the other side of the country to
seattle
because not only is russell wilson
present for off-season workouts in
seattle unlike
another disgruntled quarterback or two
russell wilson is speaking to reporters
and russell wilson would like us all to
know that
back when things got a little bit hairy
in february
he did not ask the team to trade him
here's russell
i think there are some you know uh
unfortunate frustrations after the
season obviously you want to win it all
and do it all and
do everything you can you know and i
think everybody on our team does
we all want to win it and um you know i
think unfortunately
it got a little uh you know a little bit
blown out of proportion a little bit
um i think that my ultimate goal is to
win you know
i get paid to win i get paid to find a
way i get paid to for us to be able to
make a play
you know continue to find ways to win um
and we've done a lot of that over the
years
and uh you know the mission is to
continue to do the same but do a little
bit more
and i think the reality is is that
that's the only thing i'm focused on
is winning and doing whatever it takes
to win that's why i wake up every day
and lace my cleats on and train every
day
and that's what my teammates are doing
too and so that's what i'm looking
forward to
um you know in terms of the trade talks
i think anytime you play professional
sports
there's always a possibility of
something happen right and i think
that's just the reality i think that
there's a lot of teams out there that
people were saying that i was going to
or would go to i requested a trade i did
not request a trade
um i've always wanted to play here um
you know and the reality is like you
know
i think calls were getting thrown around
and this and that and i think that's
just a reality
um but i think at the end of the day the
real reality is that i'm here
and i'm here to win i'm here to win it
all what was the intent of having your
agent
give 14 public so publicly well i think
there's a lot of confusion
uh because the reality is is that i
forget i think i was in the bahamas or
somewhere
and everybody was saying that i
requested a trade and that wasn't true
so we made it clear that i did not
request a trade
and then there was teams being flown
around that i was going to go to those
teams this and that and so
you know i think that you know when you
look back at it you know it's it's part
of
uh i don't know it's it's part of it um
unfortunately
um you know and i think that you know
more than anything else
you know that i got my wish you know in
the sense that i've always wanted to
play here that's that's where i am
that's where i am right now and uh
that's that's what i've always hoped for
ever since 2012 when i put all the names
in the hat and pulled up seahawks out of
a hat
you know and then sure enough about i
know 30 days later
the seattle seahawks picked me so you
know that's that's my mission that's my
goal and that's
that's why i'm here today and ready to
roll
okay i mean that's fine i wouldn't have
expected
anything else from a guy who had been
rehearsing
and conducting press conferences since
he was a little boy that's well
documented he's
he's been groomed for these moments and
he really couldn't have said anything
other than what he said
not that anyone who's been paying close
attention to the story is going to buy
it
i it has never happened before that i'm
aware of
miles that a franchise quarterback's
agent has come out
and said my client doesn't want to be
traded but in the event that he is
here are the four teams to which he
would gladly accept
a change of address raiders bears
cowboys saints that's never happened
before
and you could tell that he was about to
just
tap out when it was getting close to
that point and if
if there would have been a break for
someone to kind of pounce and ask him a
tougher question that's a problem with
press conferences you don't get the back
and forth you would in an interview
but if someone had a chance to really
grill him on this
he's not going to hold up very well
under questioning
because obviously he authorized his
agent
to say what he said this wasn't a
product of teams being thrown around no
teams were being thrown around what was
being thrown around is this guy wants
out and while we're trying to come to
terms with him wanting out that's when
his agent drops the four teams he played
for miles so
look again he said what he had to say
because now he's in
seahawks mode because he has no choice
he didn't get traded
so he's gotta love the one he's with
until next february
when he tries it all over again maybe
with some other strategy
ah yes there is a rose and a fisted
glove and the eagle
flies with the dove and that's why he's
got to be able to just say i love the
seahawks man and i have always wanted to
be here
and that is just the beautiful thing i
think about this is that
when you have russell wilson and when he
starts talking he just
like you said he's been rehearsing how
to be in press conferences since he was
a little kid and like that just makes
him the robot
of all of the robots but you can't tell
me
that things got blown out of proportion
when your
agent was the one who released the list
of four teams that you would be traded
to
in the event that you had actually
requested a trade so i don't know
that anybody was actually saying that
russell wilson had requested a trade
at least the way i recall things going
on back in february when all this stuff
started coming out i just feel like it
was more
one day you know we had heard after uh
he went on the dan patrick show and all
that
different stuff that if he won if he was
going to be traded
then these are the four teams that he
would want to go to and i don't recall
ever hearing something like that either
especially when
it's a franchise quarterback who was
just in the postseason
and i mean they did pretty well that
year right they won the division did
they win that playoff game against los
angeles rams at home no they did not
but i think russell wilson is still in a
position where it's like
wow he would get traded to these four
teams that's a big big deal
and you can't say that that's blown out
of proportion it's not
i didn't ask for a trade because i
didn't have to ask for a trade because
my discontent was well
documented by virtue of the things i
said
into a microphone with dan patrick that
was
all contrived engineered manufactured
that
played out exactly the way that russell
wilson
and his agent mark rogers wanted it to
play out
wilson pulled the pin himself on live
radio and tv
you don't need to go knock on pete
carroll's door after that
you've made your discontent known not to
mention how miserable he looked
sitting in the luxury suite with his
wife and the commissioner
watching tom brady and patrick mahomes
playing the game
that russell wants to play in every
single year gotta win gotta win gotta
win gotta win i don't know that you and
i have had this conversation but i
really continue to be fascinated by the
disconnect between
telling little kids why do you gotta win
all the time let somebody else have a
turn
and admiring adults who are obsessed
with winning winning winning winning
winning it can only be winning all i can
do is win i have to win i'm here to win
i gotta win
it's not how you play the game it's how
you win the game but regardless
it it torments him this is a guy who
wants to be regarded as the greatest of
all time
and maybe if he was with the right team
he'd be on that path that's what he
believes
he believes he's patrick mahomes stuck
in a team that wants him to be jim zorn
and that's where the pressure is that's
why this isn't going away
unless shane waldron the new offensive
coordinator miles
turns this guy into patrick mahomes it's
not going away
no it's not and you know i think the
interesting thing that we all know is
that pete carroll
wants to win these games by running the
ball controlling the game and playing
really really good defense
that's that's who pete carroll is that's
who they've been the entire time that
pete carroll has been there and the one
time they
didn't was you know last year when we
started talking about let russ cook let
russ cook
and it worked for a while up until it
didn't and then at that point
pete carroll reverted to who he is at
his core
which is we're going to run the ball
we're going to control the game we're
going to control the clock and we're
going to try to play as good a defense
as we possibly can
that's how they won the division last
year that's how they've been successful
for
however long it's been that pete carroll
and russell wilson have been together i
mean it's almost been a decade of
success that they've had right
so when you're looking at it from that
perspective
i understand why pete carroll wants to
do the things that he wants to do
but i do also understand russell wilson
who feels like man
i am very good everybody around this
league regards me as one of the top
quarterbacks in this league
i want to be able to play a situation
where i can win championships
and then my legacy is such that i am
thought of as one of the greatest of all
time and anybody who thinks that players
don't think about their legacy are
sorely mistaken because of course they
do
and like you were just said like you
just said mike everybody thinks about
winning
that's how they do this that's how
driven they are that's why they're
successful
so of course he's going to be thinking
about how are they going to think about
me
once i'm out of this game
tom brady's got seven patrick mahomes
has one aaron rodgers has one russell
wilson has one russell wilson wants more
than one he wants
all of them and this tom brady
experience from last year
i think has thrown a wrench into so many
franchises from the standpoint of
getting their quarterbacks to the point
where
they look at what's going on with brady
they say i'm better than that guy
i can throw it farther i can run faster
i can win better if i'm in a spot where
they listen to me remember the report
from the athletic
that after the seahawks lost a couple of
games when
other teams were catching up with the
changes they made offensively to let
russ cook you come out of the gates for
the first six seven weeks everything's
fine
then they pick up your tendencies and
your tells and they start shutting you
down you don't know how to counter it
because you're not self scouting
yourself the way that you should
he comes in with some ideas in advance
of the thursday night game against the
cardinals and they basically politely
tell him get the hell out of here or not
politely
but you just work here that's that's
what this all comes back to
the you just work here attitude that's
the attitude
that's been directed to aaron rodgers
that's the attitude that's been directed
to russell wilson that's not the
attitude
that's been directed to tom brady that's
the core of this
and that's why russell is
was let me conjugate properly is now
accepting of his situation was
in february trying to find an escape
route and one of the ways that he made
his discontent clear
was in expressing dissatisfaction about
the number of sacks that he takes he was
asked yesterday about
whether that has necessitated any type
of heartfelt conversations with the men
charged with the task of blocking for
him here's the question he was asked and
his answer
the comments you made about the
offensive line and being frustrated with
getting hit some people have taken that
as
maybe criticism of the offensive line do
you feel like that's anything you would
need to
sort of clear up within the offensive
line or do you feel like you know did
you mean that as sort of a direct
criticism of
the offensive line in general not not at
all about the offensive line i think
that i also
mentioned you know i mentioned that you
know the reality is is that i can do
better too you know i think that's we're
all we're all trying to find ways to win
all trying to find ways to be better you
know and i think that you know listen i
dwayne brown is one of my closest
friends man that guy's everything to me
you know i think about d
lou and what a player he you know he he
was last year he's going to the second
year
you know i think about guy like posik
who's been tremendous up front and how
smart he's been
i'm excited about gabe jackson he's been
amazing in the zoom calls he's been
amazing in his
approach uh how tough he is i've watched
a lot of film of him
um you know and just how good he's been
um
you know and then obviously shell over
there at right tackle you know and and
you know got a lot of other guys that
can play to as well so
i i think that you know anything about
you know a guy like kyle who stepped in
to play center for us in a big game last
year against the rams and
you know played injured and played
dinged up and all that um
you know i love my teammates the reality
is is that you know guys i
think about guys like bobby wagner a guy
i've played it's going to be my 10th
year with him you know how special he is
and
and how special our bond is you know i
think about a guy like d.k metcalf he's
like
my little brother tyler lockett who's
you know one of the most
you know unbelievable people you could
ever meet but also talented guys you
could play with
i think about the hard work freddie
swains put in chris carson i think about
you know our you know jamal adams and
how amazing he's been
addition to our team you know obviously
diggs and
and other guys as well and um you know
so for me
you know playing on this team means a
lot to me winning uh means everything to
me
and i think that's uh the heart of
hearts of and i and and everybody on my
team and everybody in our team
in the locker room they they all know
that about me is that i'm gonna do
whatever it takes to win and try to find
a way to win every play every moment
every second
and uh you know that that's just in my
blood
i i like how he looked away to make sure
no one
from his team was sneaking up on him
they were listening to that look hey i i
love russell wilson i do i think he's a
great quarterback
and i understand why he says what he
says i get it i get it
right he's saying what he thinks he has
to say whether he truly believes it or
not
it's a different issue he's saying what
he thinks he has to say and we always
knew there was going to be a reckoning
when he said what he said back in
february
we knew there was going to be a cleanup
on aisle five at some point
and the mop and the bucket were going to
be out and
i just think it was funny that that
he starts off you know rattling off the
names like hey guys
hey i said all your names how can you be
mad at me i said all your names
and then while he was at it he just
started throwing out every other name he
could think of on the team
because if he said enough names maybe by
the time he stopped talking
the reporters would forget what the
topic was i think it's brilliant miles
oh yeah oh man i love all my guys up
front gabe jackson just got here see i
know your name too my guy but
look at the defensive side we've got
bobby wagner
oh my goodness jamal adams i love this
guy too i mean i wish i had started
counting all of the names that he just
started saying when he was doing that
because that was one it reminds me of a
couple years ago when the rams were in
the playoffs and sean mcvay started like
rattling off all those names i think
actually it was before the playoffs when
he was talking about the bears against
the bears
yes yeah they've got all these guys on
defense and i know every single story
don't get me started at a head coach
who's an offensive expert
happens to know the name of all starters
on the defense
he's about to play that weekend and
everyone was amazed
he knows all their names
almost got myself in trouble no crappy
does
whoa yeah exactly yeah no bleep right
yeah exactly he should know the names
that's exactly what they're trying to do
they're trying to attack those guys
but yeah i mean wilson i think you're
right he knows exactly what he has to
say so he then goes out there and he
says it but like
when you look at what he said on the dan
patrick show he said
we have to get better up front that is a
direct criticism of the offensive line
and so whether or not he's gonna say no
i do
i have to apologize no i don't have to
apologize i'm gonna admit that you
needed to apologize in a press
conference at least
i i probably wouldn't especially if that
thing is on zoom and i'm looking into
you know a laptop and i'm not actually
seeing people in person and so i think
that
maybe they can't quite read my body
language as well as they might be able
to
otherwise but you can't say again that
this is not what you said
when you said it we can go back we can
listen to the quotes we can read the
quotes we can
watch it because it's on a clip on
youtube right like it's there it's there
in 4k
man they caught you so i don't really
know what else you want to say
russell wilson but like once you start
rattling off all these names yeah it
does sort of serve as like
a little distraction from maybe the
topic at hand
there was a tom miles back when you were
probably collecting cleveland browns
football
cards and picking out the ravens cards
and throwing them into the fireplace
where peyton manning after a playoff
loss
said i'm trying to be a good teammate
here let's just say we had
problems in pass protection and got
killed for it destroyed for it
and what he said was about 15 degrees
tamer than what russell wilson said with
his own mouth
back in february when he was trying to
agitate for a trade
without actually saying the words trade
me
so again clean up on aisle five i get it
the dog went somewhere that the dog
shouldn't have gone gotta
gotta have that pet cleanup gotta do it
i get it
but but look you he can't take away what
you said
and you said what you said for a
specific strategic reason there are no
accidents with russell wilson
and he knew at some day if he didn't get
the trade that he wanted
he was going to have to put the
toothpaste back in the as shereen
williams would say toothpaste holder
that's it it's that simple it's that
simple so you accept it for what it is
we knew it was inevitable he's going to
try to make it work this year
and if it doesn't we're going to do it
again next year it's going to be aaron
rodgers and russell wilson where are
they going to be traded to
next year if it doesn't work this year
for the seahawks
yeah well it's just we're in a situation
where
now that it's gone it's over right you
know you're not going to trade russell
wilson at this point at least
i don't think that you would because if
you do then probably wouldn't be very
competitive
in what's going to be a very competitive
division that is the nfc
west this season so i just feel like
until there is some sort of real
tangible resolution i don't know that
we're gonna get that
in seattle with russell wilson just by
the way things have gone here over the
last
year or so then this is going to be the
cycle that continues to come up so
look i mean russell wilson in seattle
they seem to have mended fences enough
to get by
this year but i mean i i just don't know
that we're going to be able to say yeah
russell wilson is going to be a seahawk
for life
at this point it just doesn't seem like
to me that's going to be the case
when he did his last contract two years
ago someone said to me this is the last
contract he's doing
with the seahawks and i still believe
that he's got three years left
he's got three years left typically it's
time to go back to the well
with one year left so we're two years
away from the next negotiation if he's
even there in two years
next negotiation is going to be 50
million plus and at some point it's
it's it's very simple at some point
he wants more than what he's worth to
the seahawks because the seahawks don't
use him
the way that they should be using a guy
like russell wilson that's what he
believes that's what others believe and
the only way we're gonna find out
is if he goes to a team that uses him
like patrick mahomes that's it
plain and simple and that tension is
gonna be there you can set it aside
from july through whenever your season
ends but
it comes back especially if you don't
win especially if you watch tom brady
get number eight
or aaron rodgers or patrick holmes get
number two and double your
output of super bowl wins so it's not
going anywhere
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports